Non mais à la fin il m’angoissait !
Mais moi j’ai dit stop.
Ouais, bah je comprends.
Il parle.. Je comprends.
En même temps il était hyper…
Collant !
Non mais je te jure,
c'est angoissant les gens comme ça.
Mais t’aurais pu un peu le creuser.
Ah mais creuser ? Mais c’était…
Tu te fous de ma gueule en fait !
En fait tu te fous de ma gueule !
Et moi c’est ça qui…
T’es en train de me…
Non mais me tape pas !
Mais si je te tape putain !
Je te tape parce que t’es en train de me rendre ouf
sérieusement putain !
C’est ça le truc
t’es en train de me rendre complètement tarée !
Putain tu te fous de ma gueule !
Tu te fous de ma gueule, j’en ai marre putain !
J’en ai marre !
J’en ai marre de passer du temps après toi putain !
Pourquoi tu fais ça ?
C’est que tu te fous de ma gueule !
J’en ai marre ! Putain mais t’es un…
Eh oh on se calme !
T’es en train de me rendre ouf !
T’es en train de me rendre ouf sérieusement !
Putain mais qu’est ce qu’il y a ?
Qu’est-ce que tu veux là ?
Calme-toi...
Toi mais ta gueule !
Non, mais non, mais Elise !
Putain…
Pardon, je suis désolé…
Pardon, je...
Excuse-moi, tiens regarde, juste pour me faire pardonner,
tiens, excuse-moi.
Merci.
Ça va Agathe ?
Comme j’ai pas bu depuis que j’essaie d’avoir un enfant…
Comme ça fait 19 mois et une une semaine.
Parce que je viens d’apprendre aujourd’hui
que mon utérus avait un sacré problème…
Non mais arrête...
C’est pas le moment de parler de ton utérus...
Non non mais en fait ça me dérange pas du tout,
je suis dans un stade où là j’adore parler utérus.
Ça me plait.
Ah bon bah super parce que j’ai un lourd sujet là-dessus !
Bon bah enchanté, Nicolas.
Enchantée, Charlotte.
Agathe.
Ok.
Bon, bah j’espère que
ça va s’arranger quand même avec ta copine.
J’ai plus du tout envie que ça s’arrange,
je me plie dans tous les sens depuis un an pour elle,
j’essaie de faire en sorte que tout se passe bien,
elle est jamais contente, donc c’est l’horreur.
Oui ça c’est sûr elle a jamais l’air contente.
Enfin en tout cas là elle était pas contente !
Je suis désolé les filles,
je vous souhaite une bonne journée,
je vous demande pardon, vraiment.
Bah écoute…
Désolé.
Tu sais quoi en fait, enlève ton t-shirt.
Pardon ?
Il est tâché, retire ton t-shirt.
Tu sais, je le prends, je l’emmène au pressing,
T’arriveras jamais à nettoyer toutes ces tâches toute seule.
Et puis franchement, c’est pas pour te vexer,
mais t’as pas une tête de femme d’intérieur !
Tiens, regarde hop.
Non mais arrête, mais qu’est-ce que tu fais, là ?
Non mais ça me dérange pas du tout,
déjà je suis super gêné, donc…
Mais non mais on s’en fout,
il m’a coûté 20 balles ce t-shirt.
T’habites loin ?
Non, non, j’habite juste là, là, la première rue.
Bah voilà, un t-shirt c’est un t-shirt,
je te le ramène, il y a pas de souci.
Je regarde pas, si c’est ça qui te gêne.
Voilà.
Je peux avoir ton 06 ?
Ah non non attends, tu rigoles,
je te file pas mon numéro de téléphone !
C’est juste parce que je veux récupérer ma veste.
06 18 00 85 38.
J’ai jamais vu une drague pareille…
t’es pas farouche en fait !
Ah, ah, ah !
Bon je te le nettoie. Ok ?
Bonne journée, je suis désolé.
Bah ok, bah salut alors.
Quoi ?
Bah il te plait.
Quoi, lui, là ?
Oui.
Mais tu rigoles ou quoi !
Bah si !
Arrête, il fait 1,20 mètres,
il a pas de cheveux,
et je fais pas dans le coton tige moi.
Ouais et puis tu donnes ton numéro de téléphone
et puis t’es à poil.
C’est vrai que je suis à poil moi !
Ouais… !
Bah vas-y, tu me racontes rien, mais dis-moi !
Non mais tu devineras jamais.
Bah non je devine pas, dis-moi.
Vas-y.
J’étais en train de travailler,
chez moi, je regardais mes photos,
très contente de moi.
Et là il m’appelle.
Ouais, tu me rejoins ?
Quoi là ? Maintenant ?
Ouais.
Moi je dis non, évidemment.
Oh bah attends, quand même, la … haute.
Minimum !
Et là il commence à décrire comment je suis habillée.
Moi j’adore les meufs qui ont des petits pulls
avec des hiboux roses,
des petits yeux en forme de bouton.
Comment ça des hiboux roses avec des boutons ?
Welcome to the new world !
Il avait trouvé où j’habitais.
Non, arrête.
Si, si.
Ça fait flipper, non ?
Ah bah évidemment que j’ai flippé !
Et puis je suis sortie, il était devant.
Il avait installé une table avec du champagne.
Mais non ?
Je te jure…
Pas lavée, pas repassée,
pas empaquetée, pas au pressing,
désolée !
C’est pas grave…
Incroyable !
Attends mais il t’a complètement eue quoi !
Ah ouais, ouais, mais enfin attention,
je me suis pas laissée…
Attends vous avez rien fait ?
Non, non, il a ramé un peu.
Ah !
Si madame veut bien se donner la peine de s’assoir.
Non, je suis désolée en fait, j’ai plein de trucs à faire,
je vais pas pouvoir rester.
Arrête là, il est 19h, tu es encore en pyjama.
Et alors ?
Bah je sais pas mais à part t’épiler la moustache
et parler de ton chômage avec ta copine qui a plus d'utérus,
j’ai pas l’impression que tu sois débordée…
Non et puis franchement, je suis magnifique
non, je sais pas ? C’est pas mal.
Sauf que je suis pas au chômage.
Ah ouais, tu fais quoi ?
Bah je suis entre deux boulots.
Mais je suis pas au chômage.
D’accord, donc ça s’appelle le chômage.
Non, ça s’appelle… enfin là oui, mais…
En fait avant, je travaillais dans… enfin j’étais juriste.
Et puis maintenant, je me lance dans la photo.
D’accord.
Voilà. Et donc en fait on a commencé à boire du champagne.
Et toi tu fais quoi ? Tu cambrioles des apparts ?
Tu fais les sacs des vieilles ?
Ouais, c’est à peu près ça ouais.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais je suis commercial, je gagne 8000 euros par mois mais
je me fais chier à mourir.
D’accord…
Ouais.
Et donc tu mets des tables pliantes devant chez les gens ?
Ah non, non, non.
Ça c’est la première fois, c’est parce que tu m’inspires.
T’es vraiment magnifique, c’est hallucinant.
C’est bluffant en fait.
Donc tu t’es assise.
Bah à partir de ce moment-là,
je me rappelle plus, gros black out.
Et ah excuse-moi si je suis pas super en forme,
si je suis pas hyper drôle sur toutes les blagues.
C’est peut-être parce que tu me déstabilises, tu vois.
Il y a peut-être cette possibilité-là.
- Peut-être.
D’habitude je fais rire que les boudins,
donc là c’est vrai que c’est la première fois…
Non mais attends tu m’en parles, t’as un sourire jusqu’ici !
Regarde !
Non mais attends, mais il t’a complètement eue là !
Euh bah…
On se casse ?
Où ça on se casse ?
On va chez moi ?
Non mais ça va pas ?
Non mais flippe pas !
Moi je veux juste dormir avec toi.
Toute façon j’ai jamais couché avec une meuf
qui porte des pulls d’enfants.
Vous vous êtes séparés ou t’as conclu ?
Ah non, j’ai joui !
C’est horrible, je sais déjà comment ça va se passer,
on va s’aimer à la folie,
Ça va te faire flipper, tu vas tout détruire.
T’es con !
Tu vas me tromper, je vais le savoir,
ça va me briser le coeur,
Mais je serai tellement accroc que je te pardonnerai.
Et puis toi tu recommenceras,
encore et encore, jusqu’à ce que j’en puisse plus…
Ta gueule.
Bon et toi alors, avec Enguerrand ?
Bah… non mais il réalise qu’il a pas forcément…
enfin il a pas forcément envie d’insister, tu vois.
Mais moi j’y crois et je me dis que ça va, ça va…
faut juste qu’on persiste un tout petit peu, c’est tout.
Mais oui !
Mais oui je sais.
T'es magnifique.
Non mais parce que -non mais reste les yeux comme ça.
Ça te fait ressortir le vert.
Pardon, mais t’es sublime.
Attends, et regarde légèrement vers là.
Et maintenant, regarde-moi.
Tu crois qu’il faudrait que je change la typo ?
C’était un architecte qui m’avait demandé…
Trop marrant !
Ça a été une commande, je te jure.
Moi c’est la première fois que…
Que quoi ? Que tu couches avec une nana ?
Pas du tout.
La photo de mon expo, je l’adore celle-là.
C’est une de mes premières photos.
Pourtant, l’expo a l’air pas mal,
l’affiche est moche je trouve.
Oh ! Pourquoi tu dis qu’elle est moche ?
Je sais pas.
La photo est belle… c’est quoi, c’est la photo ou l’affiche
?
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a ?
C’est la première fois que je ressens ça pour quelqu’un.
Quoi ?
Je ressens un truc hyper étrange !
Oh bah écoute !
Bah, oui ! Je sais pas, ça s’apparente à du mépris !
Ah bon ?
Ouais.
Alors ça c’est une photo qui m’intéresse, elle est…
Ah bah tu vois, ça c’est une photo…
Le coup de foudre, ça te parle ?
Vas-y lâche ton téléphone sérieusement.
Oui mais…
C’est juste je comprends pas, ça fait trois jours,
pas un message, rien.
Et même pas un like sur Facebook.
Ouais non mais attends, c’est normal,
lui t'a dit qu’il t’aimait
et toi tu lui as dit que tu voulais pas être en couple.
Tu vois ?
Non, non, il m’a pas dit qu’il m’aimait.
Il m’a dit qu’il avait eu le coup de foudre.
Excuse-moi, c’est vrai que c’est pas du tout la même chose…
Ça n’a vraiment rien à voir.
Qu’est-ce que je fais ? Je l’appelle ?
Mais oui ! Qu’est-ce que t’as à perdre ?
Au pire, il sera avec une meuf, et puis voilà.
Quoi ? Une meuf ?
Bah ouais, t’es pas avec lui, il a le droit, non ?
Oui, oui, non mais c’est vrai.
Bon allez viens, on va bouffer.
J’ai pas très faim en fait…
Pourquoi vous êtes ici ?